at their Brussels meeting on march six  EU environment ministers adopted the  submission of the intended nationally  determined contributions ahead of the UN  climate change conference set to take  place in Paris in December the  submission confirms that the EU and its  member states are committed to a binding  target of at least a 40-percent domestic  reduction in greenhouse gas emissions by  2030 today's we all together adopted the  so-called submission of intended  nationally determined contributions and  ec jose you and its member states it  sets out you ambitions this important  element on the road to paris by being  one of the first to submit it the youth  shows the example and invites other  countries to follow the council also  addressed climate change issues of the  energy union focusing on decarbonisation  of the economy finally ministers worked  on the post-2015 development agenda to  be adopted at the UN General Assembly  summit in September 2015